This is the story of four sisters.
They lived in Boston in America during the Civil War.
Their father was away helping the army,...
...so they lived in the house with their mother and Hannah, their servant.
Margaret was the oldest.
She was sixteen and was very pretty.
She had blond hair.
Her family called her Meg.
Next came Josephine.
She was a tall fifteen-year-old with long legs.
She wished that she were a boy.
Her family called her Jo.
The third sister was Elizabeth.
She was thirteen.
She was a very quiet, shy girl.
Her family called her Beth.
The youngest sister was Amy.
She was thin and had blue eyes.
She thought she was very important and behaved like a lady.
Their mother was Mrs. March, and they all loved her very much and tried to please her.
She worked hard to help the army by making clothes.
The girls called her Marmee.
The March family did not have much money.
They still had their house and Hannah to help them, but their clothes were old,...
...and sometimes they did not have enough to eat.
Life was sometimes difficult, but they always tried to be happy and help each other.